[Music]
on this Saturday night Fallout after the
US blocks a demand for a ceasefire in
Gaza with reports nearly half of gazans
are starving we need more access we need
to get into Gaza desperation mounts and
another Hamas hostage dies farri
concerns following the arrest of two
adamw from members in Canada they were
very good at attracting young dis Ed
individuals why authorities are growing
[Music]
nervous a Heroes welcome home in
Manitoba for the new afn Chief but Cindy
woodhouse's new job will be anything but
easy and from Mania to morning sh Otani
says no to the Jays and yes to the
Dodgers for reportedly astronomical
deal global national with faren Asser
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us the world
food program says half the population of
Gaza is starving and he is urging Israel
and the International Community to
significantly increase the amount of Aid
entering the besieged Enclave Israel
says it's preparing a system to allow
more Aid to get through but onlookers
say the plan isn't enough the Poli come
as a fighting rages inside Gaza for a
10th week the Hamas run healthman
Ministry says a barrage of Israeli air
strikes killed dozens more today pushing
the death toll in Gaza to more than
17,700 since October 7th adding to the
devastation anger growing inside and
outside Gaza over the United States
decision to veto a call for a ceasefire
in the conflict Redmond Shannon has
tonight's top story and a warning some
of the details and images in this report
are
disturbing another scene of Devastation
and death in Khan Yunis as gaza's second
city is flanked by Israeli tanks and
troops the result of the latest air
strikes is measured in bodies and etched
on the faces of
survivors this man says the US made
weapons support Israel's killing of our
women children and elderly adding that
America's veto at the United Nations
targets innocent people in Gaza inra
against on Friday the United States was
the only nation among the 15 member un
Security Council to vote against a
resolution calling for a ceasefire
saying a full ceasefire was
unrealistic it is one of five permanent
members that can veto the UK
abstained Turkish leader Reb Ty erdogan
led the condemnation he said a just
world is possible but not with America
calling for reforms within the UN
Palestinian leader in the occupied West
Bank mmud Abbas said the vote makes the
US complicit with Israeli war crimes
Israel denies targeting
civilians Israeli leader Benjamin
Netanyahu thanked the US for its veto
saying other countries should understand
that a ceasefire would just prevent the
elimination of
Hamas the un's world food program says
this ongoing War inside an area walled
off from the world is like no other the
half of the population are starving uh
you know nine out of 10 uh are not
eating every day I mean obviously the
needs are massive deputy director Carl
scow says Israel must allow for the full
opening of the larger Kum Shalom border
crossing rather than Israel's plan to
use it as a staging post we have food
available in Egypt and in Jordan uh to
reach some 1 million people people in
one month and so you know we have we are
ready to roll Israel is paying a price
for this war to an Israeli news report
says 2,000 soldiers have sustained
lifechanging injuries since October 7th
more than 400 have been killed on
Saturday one of the kabut communities
attacked on October 7th said that one of
its kidnapped residents has been
confirmed dead on Friday Hamas claimed
25-year-old SAR Baro was killed in a
failed rescue attempt Colleen Redmond
Shannon in London thanks
Redmond a surprise meeting in Ottawa
today as prime minister Justin Trudeau
and foreign affairs minister Melanie
Jolie welcomed a delegation of foreign
ministers from Saudi Arabia turkey and
the Palestinian Authority the talks
weren't disclosed to the media until
after the meeting was over they're said
to have been focused on the ongoing
Israel Hamas conflict the humanitarian
crisis in Gaza and possible Pathways
forward the delegation of Islamic and
Arab Nations has made similar stops in
China Russia the UK France and the US
with a stated goal of bringing a
ceasefire to the
war two men will appear in a Toronto
courtroom Monday after being charged
earlier this week with terrorism
offenses the pair from Southern Ontario
are allegedly associated with a violent
Neo-Nazi group known as Adam wafin
division it's the third time this year
RCMP have arrested alleged members of
the far-right group as David Aken
reports it's a growing concern not just
to Canadian law enforcement but to
agencies around the
world one of the things that is
unfortunate about Adam aen is they were
very good at marketing very good at
attracting young
disaffected individuals with videos that
like this
[Music]
this Adam offen video was shown earlier
this year at a conference of researchers
and others combating hate fueled
violence Global News has learned that
the RCMP have discovered similar videos
made by Canadian Adam wafin members in
fact the RCMP arrested two men last July
accused of creating and distributing
these images which were released by the
RCMP at the time of the July
arrest just like in these us videos RCMP
sources say the videos its investigators
have obtained show Adam WF and members
in Canada with weapons and body armor
burning Canadian US and Israeli Flags
Adam wfin has been a listed terrorist
entity in Canada since 2021 Public
Safety Canada says Adam wen's members
most of whom are young white men call
for acts of violence against racial
religious and ethnic groups also against
police and bureaucrats in an attempt to
avoid Canadian anti-terrorist laws some
Adam wafin members have tried to
essentially Rebrand themselves as active
Club Canada on Friday as the RCMP
announced the new arrests investigators
released this photo with faces blurred
of participants in an active Club Canada
combat training exercise at an unknown
location seconds to Z time Adam offen
was founded in 2013 in the United States
where adamov and members have been
linked to five murders the group has
since expanded to the UK to Germany and
to Canada because of that International
element cus is closely collaborating
with the RCMP to share information about
the group's activities here and abroad
David Aken Global News Ottawa a
salmonella outbreak across this country
has now claimed five lives the
infections are linked to a brand of
cantaloupes sold in October and November
the number of confirmed cases has nearly
doubled in the last week 129 people in
Canada have been diagnosed with
samonella linked to the outbreak most of
the cases are in Quebec 17 are in
Ontario 15 in BC Pei New Brunswick and
New Finland in Labrador each have two
confirmed cases Heidi petrac reports on
what Canadians are being urged to do and
the symptoms to watch for the salmonella
outbreak connected to mikita and Rudy br
and cantaloupes worries consumers I do
like cantaloupe it's just when I heard
about the
outbreak um I just stop buying it until
they resolve the issue very disappointed
if you're getting sick eating food you
think safe the contamination detected
during routine Government testing of
cantaloupe from Mexico the public health
agency won't give any details on the
five people who died but says most of
those sick are either 65 or older or
aged five and younger and with that does
come some individuals who report
residing in a long-term care facility a
retirement home or attending daycare
affected whole cantaloupe cut cantaloupe
and other products containing it are now
recalled Canadians urged not to eat it
and to throw out any fresh or frozen
product they may have it can survive in
the environment it can be passed from
person to person passed into food
Salmonella bacteria can also pass
between the hands and mouth sympt of
infection start within 6 to 72 hours of
consumption and include chills fever
nausea diarrhea vomiting stomach cramps
and sudden headache and those sort of uh
dehydration effects you get can be
lethal three people have also died in
the United States in connection with the
outbreak and 230 people are reported
sick one American food safety lawyer
says there are likely many more the CDC
estimates that for every one person
counted there's about 40 other people
who were sickened so do the math as
Canadians now take a closer look into
their fridges Heidi pic Global News
Halifax fresh off an election win the
new assembly of First nations's National
Chief Cindy Woodhouse says she's ready
to get to
[Music]
work woodh house getting a hero's
welcome Upon returning to Manitoba
Friday she's the Third National Chief
from Manitoba and the second woman to
lead the political advocacy organization
but the job isn't easy she'll have to
balance Regional interests internally
while presenting a United First Nations
front to the federal government Melissa
Rin
reports to those who know Cindy
Woodhouse her Victory this week comes as
little surprise her entire life Built
For This Moment and this role the
political blood else
from my family her father a former Chief
of panatang First Nation 3 hours north
of Winnipeg he ran for chief when I was
4 years old woodhouse's great great
great-grandfather Richard Woodhouse a
signatory to treaty 2 in 1871 she's
spent her life in these circles finding
common ground making deals and says she
understands the Grassroots demand that
the afn remember its roots as a
resistance movement if you don't listen
to our people and you don't listen to
our if you don't answer them then
there's
problems and so to Canada we're we're
we're coming for
you previously the afn's regional chief
for Manitoba Woodhouse is a known
presence among Federal politicians it's
exciting that she's got such a good
experience uh in both being a regional
Chief but also in many of the files that
I as a minister I'm responsible for the
housing crisis and securing supports for
addiction issues and mental health will
be her first priorities along with the
23 billion dollar child welfare
settlement she helped negotiate for
first nation's victims of the historic
child welfare system how that money is
going to be distributed how it's going
to flow out into the communities is a
big question also top of mind will be
mending fences inside the afn after the
tents removal of her predecessor Rosanne
archal last year let's come together and
let's be the powerful United afn that we
are were and will be long-term Woodhouse
has her sight set beyond the Ottawa
power bubble to Canada and to Canadians
we need your support you have to work
with first nation's people in a good way
we are here in a good way calling for a
true partnership as her ancestor
intended in signing that treaty 150
years ago Melissa Ren Global News
Winnipeg a 30-hour filibuster finally
comes to an end coming up the winners
and losers in the fight over the carbon
tax m
Mr mccu cardigan M cig Mr
sagin cheers and Applause drowned out
part of what was the final vote in a
marathon session on Parliament Hill last
night after nearly 30 hours of non-stop
voting MPS were finally able to leave
the House of Commons just after 11:30
p.m. Round the Clock voting began on
Thursday as conservatives delivered on
their promise to stall the government's
agenda unless it agrees to scrap part of
its carbon tax
a tactic the Liberals have called
ridiculous and an abuse of process
Mercedes Stevenson has more government
reaction on that philster Mercedes
Colleen as we near the end of this
year's parliamentary sitting the federal
government would like nothing more than
to be out promoting their new draft
framework for a cap on oil and gas
emissions but instead they were
sidetracked this week by a conservative
filibuster over the federal carbon tax
while MPS were engaged in a marathon
voting session we managed to secure an
interview with energy and natural
resources Minister Jonathan Wilkinson in
between rounds of vote after vote after
vote in the house here's what he had to
say about the conservatives delay
tactics what's going on in the house
right now is an abuse of parliamentary
process it may be technically allowed
under the law or under the rules but I
would tell you that there is no other
workplace in Canada that would actually
allow people to be treated the way that
members of parliament are being treated
the Liberals are not only playing
defense in the chamber they are also on
the defensive over their new oil and gas
emissions cap outside the house the oil
and gas sector as well as the provinces
of Alberta and Saskatchewan have been
criticizing the plan as a backdoor cap
on production well I would say um if you
listen to the criticism there were
certainly some in the sector who think
it goes too far there were certainly
some in the environmental Community who
don't think it goes far enough um at the
end of the day we worked very hard to
ensure that we were designing this
approach that focusing on emissions that
is in within the federal government's
Ambit from a constitutional perspective
it was not focused on on uh addressing
production because that falls within a
provincial jurisdiction um if you look
at at what we have done we looked at
what are the technically feasible
emissions reductions that you can
achieve between now and 2030
environmental groups have also been
critical of the Liberals approach and as
a reminder just last month Canada's
environment commissioner said the
Liberals aren't on track to meet their
own 2030 emissions targets Colleen
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Mercedes and you can watch her full
interview with Minister Wilkinson on
tomorrow's West block right here on
global Canada has joined a coalition of
a dozen Nations to publish an inventory
of their own fossil fuel subsidies
within a year the Dutch Le commitment
was made at cop 28 in Dubai the aim is
to create a clear strategy for
eliminating them according to
environmental defense the government of
Canada has provided nearly $1 13 billion
in subsidies to oil and gas companies in
this country so far this
year the European Union has clinched a
deal on the world's first comprehensive
laws to regulate the use of artificial
intelligence The Landmark deal came
after more than 36 hours of negotiations
between European Parliament and EU
member states the proposed agreement
includes safeguards on the use of AI as
well as limitations on its adoption by
law enforcement it also details a
Consumer complaint process and possible
fines for violations if passed the
legislation wouldn't take effect until
2025 ahead Blue Jays fans dreams dashed
as arguably the world's greatest player
signs with
LA the Toronto Blue Jays and the team's
fans may have just had the their biggest
disappointment of the Season before it
even begins baseball Phenom sh Otani has
signed with the Los Angeles Dodgers
striking one of the biggest contracts in
Pro Sports history as Mike drle reports
it turns out all the Toronto speculation
over the last 24 hours was way off base
a short Fly ball away from the Rogers
Center the TVs and all the talk are
tuned to the only topic that matters in
the Baseball World at least Shi Otani OT
to Toronto seemed like a home run on
Friday blue J's on top baby we're
getting show we're going to the World
Series next year and why wouldn't he
think that baseball insiders tweeted
Otani was on his way even the control
tower at the airport believed it a very
warm welcome to everybody that may or
may not be on board to Toronto but
baseball can be fickle the plane was
actually carrying businessman Robert
herc who had some fun with it and the
same Insider who said Otani was on his
way put up a retraction the Friday Buzz
became the Saturday hangover but it
sounds like you don't want to get your
hopes up no that's actually it cuz it
would be like a like if it doesn't work
out and then just after 300 p.m. the
other shoe dropped Otani posted I've
decided to choose the Dodgers as my next
team it's what many had expected in the
first place but nobody predicted this a
10year $700 million contract that $70
million a year to put it in perspective
the top paid NHL player Colorado's
Nathan McKinnon will earn 12.6 million
this year but in the baseball economy
Otani may actually be worth it he not
only pitches and hits Otani is one of
the most marketable athletes in the
world even if he's so private he won't
divulge the name of his dog W
you Toronto fans have been down this
road before in 2019 the NBA's Raptors
were the reported Front Runners to
resign kawhai Leonard for days he was
followed everywhere until he ultimately
decided that's right to play in Los
Angeles oh well it was fun while it
lasted Mike trle Global News
Toronto finding opportunity in adversity
a BC man's motivation to change the
world
next
he lost his business in the pandemic
then he lost his home but a Vancouver
Island man has found his purpose in a
full-time unpaid job that few of us
would even consider now as Kylie Stanton
reports what began as a local oportunity
could become something much
bigger just walk the trench and getting
the garbage out means putting the work
in I treat it like a military operation
and the schedule is is just as
rigid the last 4 months I've been doing
it consistently for every day 8 hours a
day there it is it's the full-time job
Jason Perry created for himself after
the covid-19 pandemic shuttered his
business yeah I was a woodworker like a
cabinet builder the company was the
first to go his home followed but Perry
saw The Misfortune as an opportunity to
give backoo it's creating positive
energy when I'm doing it
that's kind of one of the missions and
what goes around one time I found like
25 bucks comes around people will stop
and give me give me 10 bucks 20 bucks um
I appreciate that hugely every honk
validation I get great motivated and
I'll play the air guitar for them
everything Perry plans on taking his
mission on the road this spring making
it from one end of Vancouver Island to
the other in hopes of raising awareness
for the homeless while while putting an
end to the stigma I kind of want to
create an organization doing it and if I
can do that then I'll I'll do the
country the year after getting her as
the saying goes one man's trash is
another man's treasure treasure hunt and
it seems in all of this Perry has found
his purpose I believe the less garbage
people see on their
travels the happier they'll be when they
get to their destination I love it Kye
Stanton global
news thanks for being an inspiration
Jason Perry and that is global national
for this Saturday night I'm coling
chrisy tonight's your Canada is this
chubby fox squirrel in Regina
Saskatchewan we love seeing your Canada
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers
global.com thanks for watching hope
you'll join us again tomorrow good
night
[Music]
on